monsieur hervé novelli bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france alors ce second tour des
municipales est un véritable casse tête
on sait que dans près de 5000 communes
il est nécessaire pour élire un conseil
municipal le président de votre parti
avance la date de juin avec des règles
sanitaires strictes
c'est à dire je ne sais pas ce qu'il est
ce qu'il entend ce qui était prévu
effectivement c'est que ça ait lieu au
mois de juin
mais pour l'instant on est on est soumis
à des règles qui interdisent les
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
et donc il est très difficile de se
prononcer
le gouvernement attend le 23 mai je
crois pour pouvoir disposer d'un rapport
du comité scientifique qui nous dira
dans quelles conditions le deuxième tour
peut se dérouler et et aussi comment
vont pouvoir s'installer
les conseils municipaux et l'uil parce
que vous avez vous l'avez rappelé il ya
trente mille mairie qui ont eu ce qu'ils
ont désigné dès le premier tour
un maire sauf qu'il a jamais été
installés je moi même qui suis toujours
maire de richelieu je n'étais pas
candidat à la dernière élection est donc
je suis maire maintenu en attendant
d'installation d'un conseil qui va
désigner le nouveau maire sorti des
urnes le 15 mars dernier et donc je
crois qu'on ne pourra rien savoir avant
le 23 mai je pense que le gouvernement
voudra installer rapidement les 30000
conseils municipaux des communes où le
premier tu auras souche a suffi pour
désigner le résultat et je pense que
cela devrait se passer
effectivement dès la fin du mois de mai
ou le début du mois de juin
ensuite pour que le deuxième tour se
déroule soit il se déroule au mois de
juin soit il est repoussé en septembre
en fonction des conditions
sanitaires et auquel cas se posera la
question de refaire le premier tour pour
les 5000 communes qui n'ont pas pu
désigner complètement les conseils
municipaux et qui nécessitent un
deuxième tour donc voilà la
problématique
moi je pense que l'on pourra
vraisemblablement installer les conseils
municipaux des trente mille communes qui
ont vu un résultat définitif dès le
premier tour pour les 5000 communes
restantes je crois que la décision
d'abord elle appartient au gouvernement
et puis et puis surtout elle sera prise
en fonction de l'état sanitaire de notre
pays
est ce que le déconfinement se déroulera
dans de bonnes conditions
auquel cas on pourrait éventuellement
envisager la tenue dès le mois de juin
de ces de ce deuxième tour
sinon il faudra attendre septembre je
rappelle que pour l'instant l'ensemble
des des cafés et restaurants sont fermés
et donc un rassemblent à un deuxième
tour qui devrait se dérouler et qui
verrait donc le déplacement de toute la
population ne peut pas envisager tant
que le déconfinement n'est pas totale un
calendrier dont qui est très attendu et
vous parliez de cette hypothèse d'un
renouvellement du premier tour si c'est
le cas est ce que les banques vont
accepter
et bien de prêter de nouveau de l'argent
aux candidats pour faire campagne à
votre avis oui je pense qu'elle devrait
pouvoir le faire mais ça veut dire que
les règles devraient être à nouveau
imposé puisque le remboursement aura
lieu
je pense que ça devrait pas trop poser
de problème
le conseil constitutionnel devra
certainement en délibéré pour voir dans
quelles conditions et dans quel contexte
ces les élections vont pouvoir se
dérouler
s'il ya un trop grand écart un trop
grand délai entre le premier tour tel
qu'il s'est déroulé le 15 mars dernier
et le deuxième tour il est clair qu'on
devra refaire le premier tour et donc se
posera effectivement que vous avez
raison le problème du financement
l'état devra pas mon avis assumer le
coût comme il le fait traditionnellement
d'après la loi pour les dépenses
engagées par les candidats donc là il
faudra qu'il prenne un coup
supplémentaire résultant d'un premier
tour qui devrait être rejoué
si ce délai entre premier et deuxième
tours est très long comme par exemple si
on devait rejouer le deuxième tour au
mois de septembre prochain
poserait le problème le problème plein
de la légitimité du premier tour quand
les communes qui restent à installer
c'est à dire les 5000 communes dans ton
dont on parle
une dernière question monsieur novelli
on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui cette
date un 2d de ces élections est devenu
un marqueur politique beaucoup
disent qu'il y aurait même un changement
de premier ministre
une fois les maires installé ce que vous
êtes de cet avis je ne peux pas me
prononcer ce qui est clair c'est que
nous vivons une pandémie
extraordinairement puissantes qui
affecte le monde entier du reste et qui
a entraîné des dizaines de milliers de
décès et et une crise économique une
dépression économique extraordinairement
violente
il est clair que à un moment au moment
où nous en sortiront peut-être que le
président de la république mais c'est
son choix devra engager une nouvelle une
nouvelle démarche est donc envisagé de
changer son gouvernement
mais aujourd'hui on en est pas là me
semble-t-il
et il faut s'assurer que le
déconfinement va pouvoir se dérouler
dans de bonnes conditions et surtout que
les les élections et les gir et là
l'activité économique pourrait empêcher
qu'il n'y ait trop de de chômeurs et de
misère dans notre pays
merci beaucoup à hervé mairie d'avoir
appelé d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes maire les
républicains de richelieu et ancien
ministre du à tourisme